one of the hottest forms of
transportation these days is e-bikes in
fact millions around the world are using
them to get around town
but also to have some fun kirsten joyce
found a bike shop on the southwest part
of town who is also seeing a booming
trend
yeah denise riding e-buck e-bikes that
is so fun i tried one last summer and
that extra power really makes a
difference now mcgee's used to stock
about 300 at any given time but that's
down to about 50 as the pandemic has
people exploring these alternative forms
of exercise
they sell really fast once we get them
randy mcgee owner of mcgee's ski and
bike shop off south fort apache is
talking about e-bikes
the hottest global trend in exercise in
europe it's over half the bike sold now
or e-bikes
and i think this country is headed that
way miggy stocks more e-bikes than
regular bikes he's been selling them for
at least 10 years the last two years
they've really taken off e-bikes have
multiple gears but they're heavier than
regular bikes their tires are wider as
well
and e-bikes have various levels of
electrical assistance
you can basically take up somebody
that's not very good physical shape and
they can
do stuff on a bike that they couldn't
ever do the trend has also received a
boost this year because of the pandemic
people using them to commute just for
fun but also
bike shops seeing a surge in sales for
husbands and wives who want to ride
together
my wife has switched over to one now
which is great for me because
i used to have to wait up for a lot and
now
she waits for me on the tops of the
hills mcgee says the worldwide boom in
cycles has demanded his shop
four times what it was a year ago but
because the worldwide supply chain has
slowed down due to the pandemic
bicycles e-bikes and their parts we have
a hard time buying helmets we have a
hard time buying pumps
are harder to come by fortunately sales
are good just be a lot better if we
could get more bikes
electric bikes ranging costs from about
900 to thousand
the trektown ghost starter e-bike at
mcgee's is about 1500 and right now
they're out of stock it's very popular
but a new shipment of those will be
arriving in just a few weeks time
mcgees gets in about 20 to 30 new bikes
every week
brian it's a lot of fun